well let's start with the obvious one
passwords
um what's your password Sean I'm not
going to tell you but what I will tell
you is I use a password manager to to
use make it so that I don't really know
my password so actually I don't know I
don't know what my password is and I
assume your password is randomly
generated then randomly generated quite
long yeah it's quite long and it's
randomly generated and that's that's a
good way to have a password why because
it has a lot of entropy
if you have a lot of equal combinations
the entropy is just the base two
logarithm of the number of combinations
so obviously if you have for example a
15 character password with regular
letters capital letters numbers special
characters you know you have about 80 90
different characters in your set to the
power 15 that's going to be a massive
number then you take the base to the
logarithm of it and you're still going
to end up with a lot of entropy in fact
we can take
the base 2 logarithm because we want to
have our answer expressed in bits of the
number of characters which I said is
roughly 80 and then there were 15 such
characters so that's 80 to the power 15.
and if you do the math you can ask a
calculator to do it which I secretly
have and you get 95 bits roughly so
that's not 95 possible options that's 95
bits of that's right there are 80 to the
power 15 possible options which
you know as a guesstimate I would say
would be 10 to the power roughly 27 28.
a massive number of combinations so if
you want to search through all those
combinations you're not you're not going
to get there
um so you want the number of bits to be
as high as possible for every bit you
increase your password entropy with you
double the number of searches that
someone will need to do in order to
guess your password so you can imagine
something like five bits entropy is
nowhere near enough because that just
means you need to do 32 guesses 2 to the
power five to guess the password which
is really easy in in most settings you
know this is a good way of doing it but
there's other ways of doing it so
there's a famous XKCD comic which I'm
sure everyone knows which says you can
select four sort of semi-random words
and I'm sure someone in the comments
will correct me if I misremember it
correct horse battery staple there we go
a live correction and the argument there
is that each word
has a certain amount of entropy so
the whole string is massive but it's not
a random selection of characters so we
can't simply take 26 to the power
however many letters it has
but we can look at the entropy of
individual words if you simply select
them from the dictionary so the claimed
entropy of of a word in the comic is
roughly 11 bits and then we get a much
simpler computation and we have four
words times
11 bit entropy each because they're
independent for a total of roughly 44.
it's of entropy so selecting four random
words if you do it completely at random
would get you 44 bits of entropy which
by the way is not even less than half
the size every bit is having the size so
while this is probably good enough in
practice it's unimaginably tiny compared
to a properly randomly generated
password that you don't have to remember
but there's another issue with the
scheme from XKCD which is that you
really really need to make sure that
your forwards are random you can't as a
human come up with four words and and
put them in order because then we don't
have a uniform probability distribution
and that's actually really bad for the
entropy I don't want to go into too many
details but you can imagine that people
doing word association are not going to
come up with the same set of
combinations as a computer would it's
going to be a more limited set and
that's bad it's going to reduce your
entropy if you hypothetically picked
four words that were in the top five
Mike pound did a video on dictionary
attacks so I'm not going to go into the
further details on that side but I think
it's interesting to note that the size
of the dictionary
correlate very nicely with information
Theory so information Theory here
provides a very useful shortcut to
thinking about dictionary attacks
without actually having to deal with the
nitty-gritty details there are other
applications of information theory in
computer security one obvious one would
be privacy
um one way to express the Privacy that
you you have is perhaps in the number of
bits that are being leaked about you so
consider a case where we have a hospital
with a database of patients now it's
valuable for research if researchers can
access this information now obviously
you don't want individual researchers to
be able to query the database and say
why did my own go to the hospital last
week right so obviously you don't want
researchers to be able to do that they
only need aggregate information in other
words they can pull for example all
patients with condition X and they would
get a big list but rather than having
individuals on them it only has sort of
aggregate information on them so it will
say you know they can query how many
percent of patients with condition X
have condition Y and then they will
learn something about the condition
right that's the goal but they will also
learn something about the patients at
the hospital
um
and this uses the notion of conditional
entropy we can see here we have a
conditional query so it's not surprising
that we have a notion for that so
conditional entropy is written as the
entropy of x given Y and you simply take
the entropy of X for given outcomes of Y
but then what are the outcomes of Y
there's multiple possible outcomes so
you take the expectation in other words
you're summing over all the
possibilities of Y and then taking the
conditioned entropy which is something
slightly different of the random
variable X where we know that y has some
specific outcome so we're looking at all
the specific outcomes of Y and we're
taking the entropy of x
in that case it simplifies to the sum of
the different values of Y
um where we take the entropy of X
indicates where y happens to be the case
times the probability that Y is the case
so we're just going through all the
possible values of Y saying what is a
probability that we're in this situation
and what is the entropy of X in that
situation we can further simplify the
entropy by applying the definition but
you're just going to end up with a long
formula like here now this conditional
entropy is very useful in in measuring
how much you know about the data set but
there is also pitfalls let's go to the
sort of cases that we want to capture
with with this conditional entropy so
let's say that ahead of time you don't
know anything about the patients
and now you learn somehow from the data
set the patient
a
has condition X
then what do you learn about patient a
well you learn a certain amount of bits
um
and how many bits exactly depends on how
common condition X is in the general
population so if it's a very common
disease
the probability will be close to one bit
um
if it's a very rare disease and you
learn this the the information you learn
will actually go go up right and you can
imagine if it's a one in a million
disease you learn quite a lot by
learning that this patient has that
particular disease
and and that's sort of how it's supposed
to work that's what we want but you
there's odd cases and in order to
explain the odd case I'm going to make
an analogy uh with dice because humans
are good at reasoning about dice
um so let's say that I throw four dice
die a b c and d
and I tell you that die a has a value of
4.
how much did you learn about the data
set
quarter
a quarter because it's one of four dice
that's not quite right but
it was slow I can see why
um no what you learn is you basically
reduce the total set of possibilities by
a factor of six right if you don't know
anything about the dice how many
possibilities are there well six
times six times six times six the
entropy of that you just put a log 2
around it
and this is some number it's not two
because it's binary or is there another
reason is that that's right um so you
could use any log you want but we
computer scientists love log 2 because
it gives you the answer in bits and we
like bits you can use the natural log
you get your answer in Nets you can use
at log 10 then you're an engineer
um so the log 2 of this number is about
10.3
but I told you the outcome of die one I
told you the outcome was four
um
so that means that there isn't 6 times 6
times 6 combinations there's one times
six times six combinations
so we have one times six times six times
six and we want to take the log
two of that
but before we do that let's talk about
an interesting property of the log which
is that on the inside multiplication is
addition on the outside so this is the
same as saying well the log 2 of 6 times
6 times 6 times 6. is actually equal to
the log 2
of 6
plus the log 2 of the remaining ones six
times six times six these two values are
of course the same right so we can
actually look at each die individually
and that is because they are independent
events
it's your what 11 15 coffee no no it's
um
it turns off after a while and cleans
itself uh okay so these two log values
are the same
um and this log value is just the base
to logarithm of six which is uh about
2.6 bits if you're not mistaken so we
can actually look at this formula and
say this is 2.6 bits
uh this is at 7.6 bit roughly because I
rounded the numbers they don't quite add
up to 10.3
but I assure you this is just due to
rounding which is exactly what is of
Interest here right because here we get
the log uh to base log 2 of 6 times 6
times 6 of the other three dice which
was 7.6 bits
and then the difference between those
two is how much we learned so we take
what we knew before we take what we know
after so the entropy before the entropy
after the difference between that is how
much we learned so how much did we learn
about this dice roll 2.6 bits similarly
if we learn that a patient in the
database has a particular disease
how much do we learn well how many
combinations were possible before for
the entire data set how many are
possible after the difference expressed
in bits is how much you learned this was
the good case but let's go to a case
where it's less obvious that this is a
good measure so what if instead of
telling you that day one had an outcome
of four I told you that die 1 and die 2
had the same outcome I'm not telling you
what the outcome was but I'm telling you
that they are the same outcome
okay so what's what are the
possibilities for die one there's six
possibilities what's the possibilities
for diet two
well this is not independent of die one
because I told you they're the same so
actually
there's only one remaining possibility
one times six
we take the log 2 of that number and we
get again 7.6 bits which means that by
telling you die 1 and 2 have the same
outcome you learn exactly the same
amount about the data set as when I tell
you the outcome of Taiwan
but in reality that doesn't quite match
what we want because if I tell you that
patients A and B have the same disease
I would argue that you're not learning
the same amount about anyone as when I
tell you patient a has
I don't know a specific disease right
um so these two are
equal when it comes to entropy but not
equal when it comes to sort of what we
feel is right about privacy
um still I think this is a very useful
application but we have to understand
that just because you have a certain
amount of information doesn't always
mean that the information is useful
so it's one bit of surprisal and
similarly if we plug in the double coin
flip your prediction if I'm not mistaken
was heads and tails yeah and the
probability of that being right is of
course easier to find what the
factorization is and then once you've
factored it you can just do these steps
to completely calculate the private key